[Musica]
[Applauso]
qual è la mia idea di bellezza
per voi c'è il suono quello che avete
sentito premessa alla vibrazione
sono nata shore da a causa di no e
rosolia congenita
e prima che nascessi i miei genitori
sapevano che ci sarebbero state delle
conseguenze per me non sapevano ancora
quali ma poi hanno poi sono nata hanno
capito che non sentivo perché comunque
non non reagiva agli agli stimoli sonori
e questo è stata un po la mia fortuna
perché perché hanno iniziato a
informarsi su come poteva essere
affrontata la sordità saranno diverse
possibilità ne sarei dovuta rimanere nel
silenzio
ma dovevo in qualche modo comunicare con
il mondo
e così ho iniziato a parlare
perché i miei genitori mi hanno fatto
fare logopedia per ben 12 anni
e poi c'è stato un incontro importante
con una musicoterapeuta che si chiama
giulia cremaschi tre mesi che stava
bergamo e vi suggerisco di andare a
vedere quello che fa perché è
interessante e lara lavorato per oltre
40 anni con i bambini sordi aveva
scoperto che in realtà questi bambini
sentivano percepivano la musica non con
l'orecchio ma con il corpo attraverso il
corpo
così è stato anche per me
è perché il violoncello
la signora giu la aveva consigliato ai
miei genitori
il volo nello perché è uno strumento ca
le frequenze simili a quelle della voce
umana e questo mi sarebbe stato utile
per
la mia sordità ma per stimolare ascolto
e così io a tre anni ho iniziato a
frequentare la scuola di musica privata
qui a udine
ed è stato ogni stato un lungo percorso
la musica le
diciamo che poi sia portatore dei buoni
risultati perché a un certo punto c'è
stato un episodio circa quando avevo 12
anni di età che ci come prima il mio
orecchio destro era completamente morto
per così dire
ne sentivo annulla un giorno una mattina
o lascia sull'apparecchio c'è una corsa
dal mia mamma e loretto mamma santo
scelto come se avanti certo nel limite
delle mie possibilità
era su sciascia l'orecchio destro si era
risvegliato e si era bilanciato con con
l'orecchio sinistro e consap agli esami
audiometrici hanno confermato questo
questo episodio
poi portava anche la palese acustici con
riesce una stata a contatto con con i
suoni
e
quindi ho iniziato a sentire le
vibrazioni
e la giara ascoltato anche tu potessi
parlare la tecnologia poi migliorata nel
tempo perché quando esce una targa nella
anni 80 ancora nella race non era così
diffuso il fatto che le persone sorde
potessero parlare persino suonare
e quali sarà in campo il guaio è diciamo
che dovevo confrontarmi con un mondo
pesante mentre io non sentivo però se
vediamo una che parla che suona allora
magari ci vede un dubbio ma allora ci
sarebbe
diciamo caro a metà strada
non sentivo ma sentivo un po entrambe le
cose
questo poi il violoncello
diciamo che è stato uno strumento prima
ha dato tanto le difficoltà maggiori poi
sono state
sono state quello di dover affrontare
l'intonazione
liberazione alla proprio la spina nel
fianco perché per motivo si sentiva la
vibrazione però la vibrazione mi dava
l'idea delle frequenze basse con le alte
quindi crescioni grave suoni acuti però
quando poi andiamo più entrando più nel
dettaglio che la sfida si può
distinguere un doodle
però pare un certo punto noi ha dei non
riesco più a distinguere un po meno
dando ora più che andavano così pure a
me non è più una crescente e un po
calante questo perché perché
per voi forse che sentita il suono la
bellezza sta anche nel sentire gli
armonici prole armonici vengono captati
dall'orecchio l'orecchio e che riesce a
sentire questa differenza nella
vibrazione non c'è questa informazione
ovvero o meglio c'è però ho bisogno di
del fenomeno della risonanza
nelle corde vibrano però bisogno di un
riferimento uno strumento un'altra
persona come fa una nota se mi suona un
d'or e lo scioglie anche io lì a spa
centile se la vibrazione uguale oppure
c'è qualcosa di diverso qualcosa che non
va
però quando ci sono da sola
le note si uccide susseguono una dopo
l'altra e li diciamo che non riesco a
sentire il rapporto fra una nota è
quella successiva
una relazione fra le note perché perché
per me il suono è bello comunque che sia
ha donato poco intonato è sempre un
suono
e io mi
riesco ad essere appagata dalla
liberazione
ma ci sono anche gli armonici nella voce
e io e teoricamente sapeva cosa fossero
sapevo che esistessero ma nella pratica
l'ha scoperto tantissimo tempo ad hoc
per la precisione giusto un anno fa non
lo fa ho scoperto il armonici nella mia
voce anche se canto lo avevo già fatto
ma perché mi serviva proprio per aprire
la mia voce
e porterà e poter tentare anche
attraverso altre fasce di essa
certo la vita difficile da capire però
la perdita uditiva intorno al 90 decibel
quindi è molto profonda vuol dire perché
io possa sentire qualcosa senza
apparecchi deve passare un camion un
enorme camion molto grosso e rumoroso
oppure uno djembe africano
oppure una porta che sbatte
violentemente in un modo molto forte
e addirittura non sentivo il mio cane
che abbaiava vicino a me
infatti spesso ci chiedeva che il mio
cane di giornara tranquillo buono nicola
tranquillo di una baia mai e invece di
notte
lui aveva capito che che io non ci sono
sentivo e quindi si sfogava una volta
era arrivato il messaggio da una vicina
di casa ma detto ma perché oggi è
riuscita ha lasciato il cane solo
l'ho detto no io sono in casa
perché stava stava baiana stava facendo
un gran casino
e quando ho dovuto accogliere il collo
un fatto una nota dormito con apparecchi
o mi sono svegliata quando anni stato ad
abbaiare ho acceso la luce rimasto
impalato ragazzi
[Applauso]
poi
certo ci sono stati poi dei
miglioramenti anche nella comprensione
dell'italiano collo poi circa
tre anni fa tre anni fa ho deciso di
prendere l'auto col mio cane il mio
gatto che c'è una partita leinster ho
fatto un giro intorno all'europa
lavorando nelle fattorie volevo tap in a
capire qualcosa di più sulla
coltivazione biologica è però in questo
viaggio c'erano tre presupposti un'ora
che in quell'anno avevo deciso di non
riacquistare la parete acustici perché
soffrivo d'acqua fani volevo darvi un
silenzio
significava partire nel silenzio
assoluto
il secondo presupposto era che
avrei dovuto come leccare solo in
inglese
ci ho messo così tanto per imparare
l'italiano assicuriamoci con gli inglesi
hanno proprio
da cap
e poi c'era
anche il fatto che
che comunque io avrei potuto pagare a
pagare il mio senso visiva anche se
quello uditivo
chi lo dovevo mettere da parte pro con
la tralascio la vista poteva
godere della bellezza dei posti che ho
visitato
ho visto tanti bellissimi posti
tantissimi colori
gialloblù
e il bello anche proprio questi sono
stato cogliere le sfumature
e contemplare contemplare quello che ci
arriva
nel tempo ho sempre o semplici
sviluppato un amore per i luoghi sin
dall'infanzia non proprio stati
il perno della mia vita perché ogni
luogo che io ho vissuto
rappresentava qualcosa ma in modo molto
intenso e diventava ricorrente nei miei
sogni
e
mi aiutava anche a sviluppare la
fantasia
e quando quando ero piccolo ha poi avuto
la fortuna che mi nonna avevano una
villa gigantesca sarà proprio un
castello con la torre del 1400
io ci ha vissuto per almeno 10 anni
della mia vita
una bambina in cui la bambina con sul
blog era veramente un luogo magico fatat
perché ogni il tar sarà sì ciao a tutta
da scoprire
quindi c'è una bellezza una bellezza che
che appartiene ai nostri sensi cioè
quella visiva cioè con la uditivi
uditiva come gli ho detto prima il suolo
per me al suolo ed è bello che lo
showroom
bello a prescindere da dall'intonazione
magari il problema è quando in quello
che noi percepiamo centro mette il
nostro giudizio perché siamo quelli
sellati un po da sempre a giudicare
qualsiasi cosa
giudico quello che si aiuta giudico
quello che vedo
però poi ci sono mi fa perdere la
bellezza del momento
e
quando io diciamo che sentendo le
sfumature
percepisco la differenza tra una cosa
non ha rispetto a un'altra
devo ritornare
devo ritornare un attimo a contemplare
lasciando stare lasciarlo stare i
pensieri che
ti nascondo in quel momento
e questo mi permette di eliminare il
giudizio
è come quando non scendiamo in tramonto
in travolto
io non mi metto a dire a chi ci va un po
di giallo qui no ci vorrà un po più di
blu ancora un po di rock
così cerco di renderlo più bello di
quello che magari già e cogei colmava
bellezza del momento sfumata e il
tramonto è passato e non mi sono goduta
l'attimo
e quindi questo diciamo che non va bene
allora appena
godere appieno della bellezza bastava
teste rimanere lì di silenzio ed
ascoltare
[Musica]
il punto di partenza
siamo sempre noi
e la bellezza va cercata in quel centro
[Applauso]